hello friends I'm Ilana welcome to my
channel today I am going to show off my
how terrifying is that you can see the
reflection of the locust handed by hey
bud
the reason I'm actually here is because
I'm going to show off my Batman
collection in more detail I did do a
full room to a video but I've gotten to
more Batman since then because I have a
problem I also hung up this hush poster
so that's cool but the real reason I'm
making this right now is because I'm
officially out of space we have to stop
collecting Batman I have to more in
order that I will be able to find a
place full because I'm very good at it
but otherwise we we done we capped out I
had one shelf like three months ago and
now I have three plus another one
it's not good so what better time than
right now to actually show off some of
these individual pieces I'm not going to
name all of them because that would take
a very long time and maybe not be very
interesting for people but I'll give you
my highlights I just got today ain't she
Purdy this is made out of
peuta meaning it's pretty solid I'm not
worried about this thing ever breaking
though I did already learn that the
swords will Bend very easy to bend into
shape just because of the material hands
are magnetized in this one is made by a
company called royal selangor who
basically makes a lot of collectibles
that look just like he does but
specifically worth mentioning this is a
samurai Batman so if I back it up you
see him on his pooch he's supposed to
look as though Batman were a samurai
which I love
obviously the second biggest thing on
this shelf and I think probably the
coolest thing on the Shelf he's the
other new one that I got that meant that
I had to rearrange everything I mean
he's huge if you've seen that in the
wild I want you to know that is the
full-size version of that Doc Knight
Returns statue there's a smaller one
that it's not the small one that is the
big one he is just so big that he makes
everything else look tiny this is
sideshow piece they designed them have
individual artists design them hand
paint them and does have an
interchangeable head that is even more
vampiric all right here I just went with
the the Batman looking head just because
I felt like it made him look a little
bit more like Batman but I do love that
this base exists so that you can
actually display this it's just that
when it's on the statue
yeah it's less identifiable as Batman I
think but basically the oddest vision
for this one is supposed to be what it
would look like if Batman had undergone
nightmare gasps and I do already have
another nightmare Batman back in
Australia but he's very vampiric I'll
show you guys the base obviously just a
very cool guy loyal there he's covered
in bats these guys are a little more
tiny extremely detailed bats and his
base is huge and cascading I feel like
there are some collectors at up that
would argue that I'm ruining it a little
bit by covering him in other
collectibles but I love things looking
busy when it comes to my collection so
that's him he's definitely one of my
favorites now love the color scheme
these guys a black and white is the name
of the series basically they have an
oddest design a unique Batman sometimes
like this guy off the back here it is
based on a drawing from that artist this
guy right here is just the the man who
lost comic series so he's more a literal
adaptation I do really love this one it
uh it looks like he's standing on his
cape though I mean this is insanely cool
too cheeky little guy so as mentioned
before this one I mean when I got it I
lost my mind it's just tiny compared to
this now but obviously from the very
popular comic turned animated film
Batman on a horse I don't know what more
you could want and we've got another
very decrepit looking zombie Batman down
the front here and that's one shelf oh
you thought that was it
no no no but to is a lot more eclectic
this is a money that is the name of the
brand that makes stuff that looks like
that this is that Batman they do a lots
of different stuff but I also really
love that he's got this little joka cogs
in his mouth they're got that matt
achieve going on
I nearly dropped it no get him sick
centerpiece of this shelf is this
vampire Batman from mondo I believe I
really love the way the cake goes around
the Wayne tombstone there I think that's
super cool I think he also came with an
interchangeable head this arm there's
cleanly pops out no magnets there and
you can't change when he's holding as
well got this little glow-in-the-dark
guy he's very cute this one's another
sideshow on it's part of a pair but
sideshow gifted me that one when I went
and visited not too long ago this is
like a light version of the black and
white series again based on one
particular oddest style but it is
plastic where the others are breakable I
think that that series is called oddest
alley this guy and other sideshow piece
and then up the back there and there and
there and there the only action figures
I really collect those guys are the
squeaks play out sky action figures very
similar thing and this will sort of give
you an indication of how I collect stuff
you know I had someone recently asked do
I collect Funko pop vinyls basically the
way I collect stuff is I want it to look
like an individual artist made it I
don't collect pop Funko's because those
are a brand making something they
mass-produced are a lot less personal
totally fine if you're into that but for
me I really like having pieces that are
indicative of the person who made them
and for all of the variant Batman's up
there that's what they call the variant
line they basically again have an artist
make a rendition of Batman in a really
unique way so I've got summer I have
spotting a freeze and a western Batman
for those go let's just show you again
he's our western boy looking sad
I will mention the playout sky figures
are awful to pose basically don't stand
up on their own that's why I don't
collect a lot of action figures in
general I don't like joints but these
things are just designed in such a cool
way that I make the exception for them
that just over-designed excessively but
I love it it's just so much personality
I'm in this guy I'm also more from
sideshow just to keep my owl who is
currently literally suspended by these
two things he's not actually on the
ground in any way so that's the first
two shelves my god that beautiful Oh
can't forget this guy this is a
Christmas tree ornament that my mom got
me for Christmas last year I like that I
can have him hanging so it just looks
like he's kind of above everyone so
moved up to my top shelf here I hope you
guys could still hear me is this metal
Batman literally from the coverall
uh-huh he just doesn't fit on any of the
other shelves now and he's wide so he
had to go up there
next to this Batmobile which is huge and
cool the top opens and lights up so yeah
first three shelves pretty heavenly the
third one is a bit of a disaster let's
go anyway if you'd seen my room tool you
would have seen what this shelf look
like originally which was I had it
specifically for boxes um I've had to
move a couple of Batmen down here so
it's not a dedicated Batman shelf I
don't feel good about it
I'm probably gonna change it it is what
it is no no that I showed off this Holly
Quinn much in that veil so this
shouldn't be this is a play out sky
Holly Quinn again designed very very
strangely I gave her a bunch of joka
heads to hold just a tongue right as I'm
saying a ton of joka heads to halls I
love this one particularly I do have the
Joker figure that those are all from in
a separate area too and then we have
this guy
he's me just got him this week he's very
difficult to put any when isn't balanced
incorrectly because it's actually his
cape that holds him up at the back
rather than this foot oh whatever
so he's a strange one to pose he takes
up a lot more room than you would think
but I love how like chunky he is I love
the way that the muscles is shaded and
he looks like someone scribbled on him
with a shoppi it's great these are just
some action figures I mean this one's
actually extremely cool I got that in
Japan it's from Batman ninja from the
animated movie these two I actually had
someone sent to me that is another
vampire Batman and this is the Mad
Hatter Batman from Arkham see both very
cool but again don't collect a lot of
action figures and then this guy who I
got for free who I don't love all that
much but it's still what it is
I believe designed by the guy who's from
My Chemical Romance but yeah again he
was he was given to me so I I don't know
as much about him as I do about the
others basically if I didn't already say
it in this video yeah I specifically
collect weird Batman I if it's something
that's not traditional I won't collect
something that just looks like Batman
I'm kind of with the exception of that
Dark Knight Returns which is still
because he's on a horse so it's still
weird but I just really love and get
very nutty and excited about seeing
different artists design a character
that I love in very different ways I
like the ones that are scary for the
most part like him if he looks creepy or
disproportionate or just sort of not
human which I feel like you can pretty
obviously tell from this collection we
have very few actual Batman's yeah I do
have more though because of course they
do also in my apartment I have a batwing
I think it's 32 inches it's pretty big
and up the top here which is like above
my kitchen
you can see more of this stuff my
original video if you like I have this
Batman who's been painted by the joke of
the year he's been graffiti so that's a
full action figure and then I have these
rainbow Batman from line DC came out
with not too long ago and another
Batmobile right then but that's pretty
much it
people ask me constantly and where I get
my action figures and toys from statues
this these are really expensive pieces
like this is $1,000 I think that might
have been too they not cheap a lot of
payment plans in a lot of careful
selection because ones that look like
this come out rarely enough that I can
buy them basically but the answer is all
over the place this is from sideshow
this was direct from the website I think
this guy was from in a store I got him
in person that was a gift that was a
gift that was from a store that was from
a completely unrelated so like one that
I never even heard of so like just comic
book stores is where I'm picking these
up I do also use Entertainment Earth Big
Bad toy store obviously sideshow I get
stuff direct from them a lot I buy stuff
at Comic Cons if I see something cool at
a Comic Con I will buy it to add to my
collection basically the answer is a lot
of different places I don't have a neat
answer for you unfortunately but hey
thanks for joining me on this video I
know there are people with much bigger
Batman collections than me I'm
definitely not trying to say I have the
biggest one in the world or the most
expensive one in the world or anything
like that but I would say probably have
one of the most unique Batman
collections in the world
I feel pretty confident in saying that I
feel like there are a lot of people who
have the amount of weird Batman stuff
it's actually kind of amazing that
they're that many variants for one
character but it certainly suits me
thank you for watching this video I have
no idea if anyone's gonna find this
interesting or even enjoy watching this
video I think this is probably most
self-indulgent than anything else cuz I
like talking about my Batman but yeah
I'll see you guys next time